[Music]
the tourism industry is worried about a
new government system that warns of
unsafe travel destinations the new
feature rates every country in terms of
safety on a 4-point scale previously the
State Department issued warnings and
alerts about specific nations CBS News
travel editor Peter Greenberg is here to
explain the concern Peter good morning
were you so how does this new State
Department system work well the old
state department system work where you
had a robust series of State Department
travel advisories warnings and bulletins
is very confusing specific countries
were mentioned but people didn't know
the difference between an advisory of
bulletins and a warning and those three
words state department advisory it's
such a negative connotation most
Americans haven't even read them they
just didn't go well as soon as they
would see that they the new one could be
but a little bit more confusing even if
it's well-intentioned because it breaks
it down for every single country into
four categories exercise normal
precautions exercise increased caution
reconsider travel and do not travel
where it gets very confusing is in that
fourth category because most people are
going to think it means it's a ban and
it's not it's not a legal definition
it's just still an advisory but look at
the condition of Mexico right now you
have five states in Mexico that are now
in that fourth category right you take
the state of Sinaloa well that also
includes Mazatlan not a problem but it's
painted with the same broad brush so
tourism officials they are very worried
because people going to say I'm not
going because it says do not go and that
reconsider travel the third kateri canoe
does that mean reconsider and don't go
at all or just spend your time in the
well-lit places where everybody's safe
you're asking the rhetorical question
nobody knows that answer because it's
it's not it's not defined so the problem
right now is what you get beyond that
first category which is exercise normal
precaution which I still don't know what
that means
Yeah right does that mean don't trip
right and then exercise increased
caution does that mean don't trip and
fall I mean I'm not trying to be funny
about it but people don't know the
difference so once you get beyond that
second category most people human nature
gonna say I'm not going so how did they
determine what rating to give a specific
country well it's broken down by four
additional categories crime health
natural disaster and terrorism and
that's a good idea but most people are
never going to get to that most people
just gonna hear those state those same
words and they're not gonna go so what
do you think would make it easy
here well for me my own personal metric
is I will not go anywhere where I don't
know who's in control it's really as
simple as that
right but putting let's say Mazatlan in
the same department as Syria and Yemen
is not really helping people if I know
it's in control I exercise my own normal
precautions and I play by their rules
and I go I see what you're saying about
Mexico favorite daughter Kirby went
there this weekend and I told her don't
go this morning the State Department
yeah she called the State Department
said I'm going should have called Peter
and said yeah thank you Peter Greenberg
we know your number